it's like if these women can't be happy
married to the top 10 20 of men you know
what will make them happy and then I
also see a common trend of like the men
saying well just find a good woman and I
really think the new standard again for
a wife really should be a virgin if
there's an 80 chance of a happy marriage
if the chick's a virgin I really think
men should hold out and start demanding
virgin but it's really only going to
happen if the top men you know do it and
we do see a trend of men walking away
from Marriage I mean
but however there are predatory women
that go after younger men and you're
going to keep seeing this trend and and
you really you you see this trend of
older women going after younger guys
that really haven't been through the
ringer yet and don't know better